we've already spoken to you about the
importance of user feedback learning
from and responding to feedback is
incredibly important but now let's hear
from an expert about their real-world
experience using feedback to learn about
their customers needs and to better
their product so I am VP at mobile a
user testing and user testing is a
company that lets you get really really
fast turnaround videos of people normal
people using your application or website
so you come to us you to find the tests
you need in the demographics and you get
videos back often in as little as an
hour so it's really fast turnaround so
what you can learn on the marketing side
is getting more insights into what's
going on in the heads of your customers
and how well are you matching what's
happening and in what they're thinking
about so it can be early stages you know
when you're working on your marketing
materials testing it out on people
finding out what sorts of things they
respond to well in which things they
don't like or it can be later on after
you've launched when you're looking at
analytics or things like that and trying
to get more insights on the behaviors
that you're seeing and what customers
are doing so times when you can use user
tests just alone are kind of there two
categories one is when you're really
interested just in understanding the
emotional context because analytics
won't give you that stuff at all it's
like how are they feeling about it you
know are they feeling engaged are they
are they interested are they feeling
like they're making progress and
sometimes when I watch the videos I
actually just look for tone of voice
more than anything else you know so so
for example if you're testing an app and
at some point during the test the user
sighs they do this you know deep trouble
I mean it could even it doesn't it could
be in a foreign language if you just
hear or it's or the tone of voices well
you know you know you can't kind of get
that trailing off tone of voice that
what that is telling you is that you're
failing to grab them emotionally which
means you're not creating the motivation
that will cause them to come back in the
future to use your app again and you've
really got a problem there that you need
to go dig into I think the second place
where the user tests can stand alone is
when the conclusions are so clear that
hey we don't need any ice on this is
really obvious what's going on and you
know one class of these is when you find
that there's particular language or
maybe an icon design or something like
that that just doesn't work for them and
a lot of teams times because the team
has been working on the app for a long
time you get this this kind of
groupthink situation where because it's
become clear to you over time that this
is how it should work or this is what
the context of this stuff means this
phrase is very meaningful to the team
for describing the application therefore
it's it's gotta mean the same thing to
the users and what you'll find very
often is it is not intuitive to them and
actually you need to step back and get
inside their head and the user tests can
show you that sort of stuff very quickly
you know theythey icon is not intuitive
they'll just look at it and say what the
heck am I supposed to do here
and that's the point where you need to
think about okay either redraw it or
maybe add a text label do you know which
is not sexy it doesn't look beautiful
but we're after usability more than we
are Beauty I mean it's great if you can
get both but I'd rather have it be
usable first and then pretty it up as
much as you can the user test can be a
great way to very rapidly get those
insights so you can fix them right in a
moment